[Music]
chris
is with us in kansas city hey chris
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave and chris thank you very much
for taking my call happy to talk with
you guys
you too what's up um so kind of an m
in 3b baby step did uh
davish for a while and got pretty
serious and paid off all the debts and
saving for a house but kind of find
where we're in the process of where the
need for a new car is becoming more of a
need as opposed to a want
and so curious if i should usually i've
been saving up to go
towards a new car stay in the house that
we're at and pay
that off or use the down payment for a
new house and try to
limp through with a vehicle how much you
got saved up buddy
i'm sorry again how much do you have
saved up currently
uh 67 000. and that's outside of your
emergency fund
uh that would be including so probably
outside would be about 47.
okay okay and how much car are you
talking about buying
oh 18 000 including tax i mean we're
talking like maybe a small
suv maybe even less than that okay
and uh what's your household income um
we're probably gonna be right about one
110 this year
okay all right and so the obvious
statement is if you buy the car it
delays the house
purchase a little bit right correct yeah
and um so it's just a choice if you know
if you feel like the
other car is going to lay down on you
then you know
we're gonna have to do something right
right right and it's not quite at that
point but i gotta
i got a feeling murphy's coming who's
who drives it chris you are your wife
i do okay well that's better what are
you yeah the new
the new car would be uh for the
wi-fi would essentially just switch cars
at that point once we got the new one
okay okay it's up to you there there's
no wrong answer here
the car you're buying is not out of line
with your income you have the cash to
buy
it so it's fine to do that uh the
obvious trade-off is you're delaying
purchasing the home a little bit to do
that
and so you're just making a call here on
that are we going to put mama
in a better situation or not right and
dave when people go to buy cars i'm
going to talk about this because i think
it's people don't they don't think about
it
if you're planning to spend 18 that
means you're planning to buy a car
that's around 15
because you're going to have tax tags
and title and things that you're going
to have to pay for
and so you know just in that mindset i i
want to have help people kind of get a
better range
of views so don't you know yeah can you
maybe get a deal on a car but
you need to be aware tax tax and title
is real yeah
it'll step up and bite you in the
process it really can